Pour ce nouveau Gentes Dames Badass, il faut
que je vous prévienne de deux choses.
La première, c'est que notre histoire se
passe exclusivement au Xxe siècle.
Je sais, vous n'en avez pas l'habitude sur
cette chaîne, respirez, ça va aller.
La deuxième, c'est que le personnage auquel
on va s'intéresser était communiste et féministe,
ce qui multiplie le potentiel de critiques
négatives dans les commentaires par le nombre
de mètres carrés de la place rouge mais:
on s'en fout, c'est ma chaîne.
Plus sérieusement le propos n'est pas de
faire l'apologie de la montée du parti communiste
en France, qu'on en fasse partie ou non et
en ce qui me concerne c'est non, mais ce qui
m'intéresse en tant qu'historienne est de
retracer le parcours d'une femme qui s'est
battue pour faire avancer les causes en lesquelles
elle croyait.
Martha Desrumaux était une ouvrière, syndicaliste,
communiste, féministe, anti-colonialiste,
résistante...
Bref: une personne plutôt badass.
Elle naît en 1897 à Comines, dans une famille
qui compte déjà six enfants.
Son père tenait un cabaret, ce qui leur assure
un petit confort de vie dans une ville fortement
marquée par l'industrialisation: les ouvriers
représentaient alors 40% de la population
active du Nord, travaillaient sans sécurité
sociale ni allocation chômage et vivaient
dans des corons ou quartiers pauvres sans
eau courante ni électricité.
Pendant ce temps là, pour les riches familles
du Nord...
Ça allait.
Les grèves sont encore fortement réprimées
en cette fin du XIXe siècle: celle de 1891
à Fourmies fait 7 morts parmi les manifestants
à cause de violences policières, c'est original.
Martha grandit dans cette ambiance de début
d'organisation syndicale, la CGT est fondée
en 1895, et de nombreux débats ont lieu dans
les estaminets comme celui que tenait son
père.
Ce dernier meurt en 1906 et laisse sa famille
dans une situation très précaire.
Ils sont obligés de déménager et Martha
commence à travailler à dix ans, alors que
l'école était obligatoire jusque 12 ans
à l'époque mais sur un malentendu, ça passait
souvent.
Elle travaille 9h par jour, 6 jours par semaine,
pour un salaire 30 à 50% inférieur à celui
des hommes et encore divisé par deux comme
elle est une enfant.
Face aux conditions de travail extrêmement
difficiles dans les usines textiles de l'époque,
je pense que vous connaissez déjà le sujet
dans les grandes lignes, elle se syndique
à la CGT à l'âge de 13 ans.
Elle ne sait pas lire mais apprend la politique
auprès d'autres ouvriers et adhère au parti
socialiste à la même période.
Elle subit la première guerre mondiale de
plein fouet, la ville de Comines n'étant
évacuée qu'en 1917.
En attendant elle doit faire avec l'occupation
allemande, le camp de prisonniers russes installé
aux abords de la ville, la destruction de
90% des bâtiments...
Elle et sa famille sont finalement envoyées
à Lyon, où elle trouve un travail dans les
ateliers Hassebroucq originaires du nord comme
elle.
De nombreuses industries déménagent le temps
de la guerre qui est aussi l'occasion de nombreuses
grèves contre la hausse des prix et les conditions
de travail.
On compte 696 grèves en 1917.
En août 1917, Martha prend part à sa première
grève pour obtenir une augmentation de cinq
francs.
Les femmes sont très nombreuses dans les
usines à cette période du fait de la guerre,
toujours, mais elle est l'une des seules à
être syndiquée.
Elle est chargée de diriger la délégation
à la préfecture et demande à ce que les
accords soient lus à voix haute avant de
les signer, puisque pour rappel elle ne sait
toujours pas lire et ne tient pas à ce que
ça se sache.
Elle apprend finalement au début des années
20, grâce à une camarade d'usine et sur
une brochure de Paul Vaillant-Couturier, l'un
des fondateurs du Parti Communiste Français.
Je ne pense pas que cette phrase puisse être
plus de gauche.
A la fin des années 20, Martha a 23 ans,
sait lire et écrire.
Elle rentre à Comines et adhère avec son
frère au PCF fraîchement crée mais n'ose
pas encore participer aux débats du parti
ou de la CGT puisqu'elle manque fortement
d'éducation politique.
Elle continue de mobiliser les ouvrières
face aux conditions de travail de l'usine
Hassebroucq, déclarant que les femmes ouvrières
souffrent d'une double peine dans le système
capitaliste: celle de l'exploitation par
le patronat, et la domination par les hommes.
Militante féministe, donc, et la cause des
femmes continuera d'être sa préoccupation
principale dans sa défense de la cause ouvrière.
Les femmes subissaient aussi une double tâche
de devoir travailler à l'usine, parfois à
1h à pieds de chez elles, et travailler à
la maison.
Lorsqu'elles avaient des enfants elle devaient
souvent renoncer à leur emploi, ce qui les
rendait dépendantes du salaire de leur mari.
Quand son patron la nomme contredame pour
contrer son influence, puisqu'elle est alors
censée surveiller ses collègues, elle transforme
ce poste en une sorte de déléguée du personnel.
Elle se fait finalement une éducation politique
en 1924 dans une école léniniste de Lille,
ce qui lui permet de s'affirmer davantage
par la suite.
Au sein du PCF elle devient responsable aux
femmes dans son secteur et organise des réunions,
des débats...
Côté syndicat elle fait aussi partie de
la commission féminine de la CGTU et prend
de plus en plus la parole à l'oral, lors
des réunions, et dans des articles qu'elle
publie dans l'Enchaîné.
Elle défend à plusieurs reprises «à
travail égal, salaire égal», ce qui n'est
pas du tout une cause encore d'actualité.
Non non non.
Elle réclame aussi des congés pré et post-nataux,
de nombreuses ouvrières faisant des fausses
couches sur le chemin du travail ou à l'usine.
En 1927 elle est invitée dans la délégation
féminine qui part à Moscou pour le 10e anniversaire
de la Révolution d'Octobre.
Son départ est un peu compliqué parce que
la préfecture refuse de lui délivrer un
passeport, elle doit se faire passer pour
une femme de chambre et voyager sous une fausse
identité.
Les français voyageant vers l'Union Soviétique
étaient pistés, et elle est découverte
en cours de séjour ce qui complique aussi
son retour.
A Moscou elle assiste à des réunions, visite
des fermes et des usines...
Elle y observe les progrès qu'on lui montre
mais garde une vision critique sur la condition
de vie des ouvrières.
Elle rentre finalement en France en traversant
clandestinement la frontière et passe les
mois suivants à témoigner sur ce qu'elle
a vu à Moscou.
Elle est aussi élue au comité central du
PCF.
Toute sa vie est consacrée au militantisme:
elle organise des cagnottes pour les différente
grèves des année 20 et 30, elle manifeste,
et grâce à elle une femme au moins doit
être associée à toutes les direction locales
de la CGTU.
Elle repart à Moscou en 31 pour participer
aux écoles internationales: elle y apprend
le russe, la philosophie, l'économie, et
y retrouve son futur mari Louis Manguine qui
est membre de la CGTU à Marseille.
En mai 36 elle participe évidemment aux grèves
qui amènent les congés payés et est la
seule femme présente lors de la négociation
des accords Matignon avec Léon Blum.
Elle apparaît dans le film La Vie est à
nous, de Jean Renoir, qui montre la vie quotidienne
des français ouvriers, paysans ou bourgeois.
Dans cette atmosphère de victoire, elle a
un fils en 1937 et épouse Louis Manguine,
le père, un an plus tard, mais ses activités
militantes ne sont jamais loin.
En 38, la seconde guerre mondiale se profile.
Elle participe à l'évacuation des enfants
espagnols, dans le contexte de la guerre civile
espagnole, mais souffre d'une campagne anti-communiste
à partir de la signature du pacte germano-soviétique.
Le PCF est dissous en septembre 39, Louis
Manguine est mobilisé.
Avant d'être dissout le parti avant demandé
à ce que ses membres repèrent des planques
et louent discrètement des appartements en
vue de la guerre, c'est donc tout naturellement
que Martha passe de militante à résistante.
Elle organise le passage clandestin de Maurice
Thorez à Moscou et est chargée d'assurer
les liaisons entre Paris et Bruxelles.
Les résistants du Nord impriment clandestinement
l'Enchaîné, qui avait été interdit, récupèrent
des armes et continuent les grèves au sein
des usines malgré l'occupation allemande.
Ils font aussi tout leur possible pour freiner
la production en sabotant les voies ferrées,
détruisant les pylônes électriques, les
péniches et les écluses, mais en réaction
de nombreux ouvriers sont arrêtés et déportés.
Tout s'accélère en août 41: le 26 août,
trois communistes attaquent un café réservé
aux officiers allemands.
Ils en tuent deux et en blessent un troisième,
en réaction de quoi les autorités allemandes
demandent au préfet une liste de dirigeants
communistes parmi lesquels se trouve le nom
de Martha Manguine.
Heureusement pour elle elle n'est pas citée
en tant que Martha Desrumaux et parvient à
garder son nom secret, car il lui aurait probablement
valu beaucoup plus de problèmes.
Elle est transférée pour quatre mois à
la prison de Loos, pendant que d'autres otages
sont directement fusillés, puis est embarquée
dans un train qui fait un long périple vers
Bruxelles, Liège, Aix-la-Chapelle, Hanovre,
Hambourg, et enfin Ravensbrück.
Ravensbrück est l'un des nombreux camps de
concentration mis en place par le régime
nazi et l'un des seuls réservés aux femmes.
Après sa libération, Martha rédige un long
texte racontant ses conditions d'emprisonnement.
Je ne vais pas m'étendre dessus car vous
devez déjà bien imaginer à quel point elles
étaient difficiles si vous avez eu le moindre
cours d'Histoire dans le secondaire, mais
en voici quelques extraits dont les premiers
peuvent choquer.
Si vous êtes sensible, passez
à ce timecode.
Martha raconte encore d'autres expériences
médicales, les personnes âgées gazées,
le travail forcé,
le manque de nourriture, d'hygiène, la violence...
La solidarité qui se met en place, aussi.
Martha est
d'ailleurs sauvée par ce même procédé,
suite à une infection de la main.
Le 1er avril 1945, elle est enfin libérée
parmi 300 femmes choisies pour un échange
avec 33 femmes SS détenues en France.
Elle arrive à Paris le 14 avril, dans un
train attendu par le général de Gaulle mais
qui choisit finalement de ne pas faire de
discours à leur arrivée en constatant l'état
d'épuisement dans lequel sont la plupart
des femmes.
Martha ne tarde pas à témoigner de son expérience,
à la radio puis une fois de retour à Lille,
étant la première déportée lilloise à
revenir d'un camp.
Elle retrouve rapidement ses activités, qu'elle
continue de mener jusqu'à sa mort en 1982:
elle co-dirige la direction départementale
du PCF, est adjointe à la mairie de Lille,
retrouve ses mandats à la CGT.
Elle continue de s'exprimer régulièrement
sur la place des femmes et de les encourager
à se battre pour leurs droits.
Elle ne quitte pas non plus le milieu ouvrier,
puisqu'elle passe la fin de sa vie dans le
quartier de Wazemmes où se trouvaient encore
de nombreux ateliers et usines.
Depuis sa mort, son nom est resté peu connu
du grand public.
Elle n'était qu'une femme issue du milieu
ouvrier, très grande et pas particulièrement
belle, souvent la seule femme dans les groupes
qu'elle fréquente mais pas assez mise au
premier plan.
Pourtant sa mémoire demeure: plusieurs
rues portent son nom ainsi qu'un collège
lillois, et depuis plusieurs années l'association
des ami.e.s de Martha Desrumaux milite pour
son entrée au Panthéon.
En 2013, François Hollande avait proposé
qu'une nouvelle femme y entre, et elle aurait
été la première femme ouvrière à y reposer.
Elle n'y est finalement pas entrée, mais
j'espère que cette vidéo contribuera à
la faire connaître.
Si vous voulez plus d'informations sur elle
vous pouvez vous rapprocher de l'association
que je viens de citer et dont je mettrai des
liens en commentaire.
C'est d'ailleurs grâce au livre publié par
l'asso que j'ai préparé cet épisode, après
avoir découvert Martha à une conférence.
J'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
éloigné de mes périodes habituelles mais
sur une femme tellement badass, et à bientôt!